au départ il a été dessinateur
publicitaire mais plus personne ne s'en
souvient et pour cause il est depuis
1963 le batteur du plus célèbre groupe
de rock du monde c'est pourtant un autre
style de musique qu'il rêvait de jouer
au départ et il s'offre en ce moment une
belle récréation dans un club de jazz à
paris voici maintenant l'invité des cinq
dernières minutes
[Musique]
et s'est invitée c'est charlie watts
bonjour merci vraiment d'être avec nous
invité exceptionnel on ne vous présente
plus vous êtes le célèbre batteur des
rolling stones c'est ce que vous
m'entendez correctement tout va bien
on vous invite non pas pour parler des
rolling stones on en parlera un petit
peu mais surtout pour parler de
l'expérience que vous êtes en train de
vivre en ce moment à paris vous jouez
dans un club de jazz le duc des lombards
en ce moment et c'était un rêve pour
vous
oui absolument jouer à paris dans un
club oui c'est moi c'était un rêve
depuis que je suis très jeune et alors
on apprend aussi enfin on apprend en
vous connectant un petit peu que votre
rêve c'est très vrai c'était vraiment au
départ de jouer du jazz dont vous vous
retrouvez la dans un groupe à jouer non
plus du rock et du jazz
eh bien regardez où que oui c'est vrai
que je voulais jouer du jazz mais
surtout du boogie woogie c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est la musique qui bouge
quelque chose de différent mais oui vous
avez raison ce que vous dites est exact
des débits ici nba boogie woogie
racontez nous ce que vous jouez sur
scène
je suis le sait je suis le batteur
en fait la bcdc bien de nos quatre
prénoms
et donc
axel les deux joueurs de piano il ya des
vides abcd donc avec ben et vous avez
repris des classiques des body body
qu'est ce que vous aviez envie de
produire comme spectacle des lombards
oui c'est du booking en effet c'est une
musique qui a connu son apogée à la fin
des années 30 au début des années
quarante et une personnes ne jouent plus
nulle part donc je lève c'est assez
intéressant justement c'est d' assez
répétitif mais c'est assez difficile à
jouer au piano notamment très difficile
et s'est amusé il s'amuse bien avec
david on fait du swing tout simplement
ça nous plaît
absolue racontez-nous justement vous
dites ça nous plaît les concerts ça vous
plaît mais qu'est ce que vous ressentez
vous qui vous produisez là dans une
ambiance plutôt intime au duc des
lombards à paris vous qui êtes habitués
au stade de france ou à des concerts
absolument immense à new york ou à tokyo
effectivement c'est vrai que le lieu est
assez intime petit et
c'est à l'intérieur et donc
effectivement il faut pas jouer trop
fort faut faire attention l'heure qu'au
stade de france je peux vous en donner à
coeur joie au contraire mais
disons que il faut réapprendre à écouter
mais ça revient au même au bout du
compte lorsque vous êtes batteur vous
fait l'ouverture la fermeture et il faut
entre les deux continuer de jouer c'est
la même chose mais c'est juste que
disant que c'est moins fort moins fort
que les rolling stones mais c'est plus
subtil disons
mais il faut avoir cette subtilité parce
que la salle est petite si vous voulez
bien
si vous voulez bien on va tout de suite
voir un extrait de ce concert parce que
tout le monde vous a vu bien sûr depuis
des années joué avec les rolling stones
semé quasiment personne en france ne
vous a vus jouer avec les avis
10 bogui of boogie woogie on vous
regarde duc des lombards c'était les
derniers concerts au regard d'ensemble
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
et
alors on a vraiment l'impression que
vous vous amusez là avec ce groupe en ce
moment à paris
j'imagine qu'il ya énormément de gens
qui ont la chance de voir ses concerts
qui viennent vous voir à la sortie pour
vous parler des rolling stones ceci
absolument route
et
non plus mais il ya quand même des fans
qui sont là qu'il
ya des fans qui me connaissent et voilà
quand on vous écoute parler des rolling
stones sont à presque parfois
l'impression que vous abordez cette
succession concert que vous donnez
partout dans le monde pas comme une
routine mais comme un concert géant qui
se poursuivrait depuis des décennies
c'est pas fou c'est une bonne façon de
voir les choses et c'est probablement le
cas effectivement ça fait partie de
notre métier on fait ça on joue
salut ah le voilà
mais vous n'avez pas nous dire quand
même que vous vous ennuyez parfois quand
vous jouez avec les rolling stones si on
s'ennuie jamais avec les rolling stones
non non non pas du tout c'est juste que
ça fait tellement longtemps que ça dure
on a joué tellement de fois ensemble non
on peut pas s'ennuyer pour autant
certains mais il ya d'autres choses pour
s'ennuyer c'est juste que c'est la
répétition des spectacles qui veut ça
mais mais non c'est pas de l'ennui
c'est pas possible de s'ennuyer avec des
gens comme ça qu'ils gagnent un nom
alors justement quand vous parlez des
rolling stones vous êtes toujours les
rolling stones c'est d'abord mick jagger
keith richards
s'est beaucoup de modestie c'est vous
aussi les rolling stones
oui ils ont les ongles c'est moi aussi
c'est
normal m'envoie vous savez je ne fais
pas ce type d'entretien je viens pas la
télé le faire des interviews plutôt me
cookies qui va faire ça justement
c'est ça que je veux dire simplement
vous avez parlé avec mick jagger avec
qui souhaitent charte des concerts que
vous êtes en train en train de donner en
se pendant à paris est-ce qu'ils vont
venir vous voir
vous écouter
non
mais que je vais parler qu'ils lui par
contre il répond pas au téléphone il
utilise jamais le téléphone non abonnés
donc
par les actifs mais pas heureusement
uniquement c'est plus compliqué contre
nick lui il était la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs
il a fait une tournée pas loin d'ici à
tour et il était à paris récemment il
est bon il a beaucoup d'appartements y
compris un appart à paris mais je le
vois régulièrement oui effectivement
mais disons que on n'a pas besoin de se
parler énormément vous savez ça n'a
jamais été le cas d'ailleurs ça a
toujours été un groupe bon travail
ensemble voilà c'est ça notre truc c'est
de travailler ensemble s'il se sent
c'est juste la chose la plus formidable
qu'on puisse faire quand on fait du rock
merci à vous charlie watts
[Musique]